في السابع من مايو من العام
1915 اغرق زورق غواص سفينه بريطانيه
سياحيه فقتل من عليها وكان منهم مئه
وثلاثه وعشرون امريكيا ما اغضب الرئيس
الامريكي توماس ويلسون هذا الحدث كان احدى
مكائد الضابط الالماني فرانزفون
فما قصته ولد فرانز رينتيلين بالمانيا عام
1878 لعائله متنفذه بقطاع البنوك فحضي
بوظيفه في بنك دويتش قبل ان يخدمه اتقانه
للانجليزيه ويصبح الممثل الامريكي لثاني
اكبر بنوك المانيا انذاك ديسكونتو ديسلسيف
في عام
1915 تحول رينتيلين من مصرفي الى عميل
بالمخابرات الالمانيه وارسل في مهمه كبرى
لنيويورك مع جواز سفر السويسري مزور باسم
ايميل قبل ان ينتحل هناك شخصيه رجل اعمال
يدعى فريدريك هانسن ويؤسس شركه وهميه بهدف
سحب البارود من السوق الامريكي حيث كان
يقوم بشرائه واتلافه كما تعاون مع
كيميائيا الماني لتطوير اجهزه حارقه عرفت
باسم القنابل الرصاصيه ثم جند عمال رصيف
ايرلنديين لزرعها على متن سفن الحلفاء
بالموانئ الامريكيه ما تسبب في تدمير
واحراق العديد من سفن الامدادات الحربيه
لعب رنتلين ايضا ادوارا سياسيه بتوجيهات
من برلين فحرض على الاضطرابات بين عمال
نقل الذخيره وتاخير وصول المساعدات
الامريكيه للحلفاء في عمليه تكلفت نحو 500
الف دولار كما اشترت ذخيره للجنرال
المكسيكي المخلوع فيكتوريانو هويرتا في
عام
1915 وشجعه على محاوله استعاده السلطه الى
دعم عمليات اغراق سفن الحلفاء اما اكبر
عملياته فكانت اغراق سفينه لوسوتينيا وهي
سفينه سياحيه بريطانيه كانت تسافر من
نيويورك الى ليفربول حيث مات الف ومئه
وخمسه وتسعون شخصا ممن كانوا على متنها من
بينهم
123 امريكيا وهي الحادثه التي كانت من
اسباب اقناع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بدخول الحرب بعد عامين بعد فتره وجيزه من
غرق لوسيتينيا وفيما كان رينتيلين على متن
باخره هولنديه ذاهبا الى برلين وبفضل
رساله المانيه تم فك شفرتها اوقفه
البريطانيون حيث اعترف بانه ضابط عدو وسجن
في بريطانيا لمده 21 شهرا كما اعتقل في
اتلانتا لثلاث سنوات اخرى دون ان توقف
شبكته التخريبيه اعمالها فقامت عمليات
كبرى اخرى كتفجير بلاكتوم وحرائق مصنع
القذائف بكينغز لاند وحريق مصنع شركه
مسحوق هرقل حيث قدر كتاب نشر في عام
1937 انه بين اوائل عام
1915 وربيع
تعرضت ثلاثه واربعون مصنعا امريكيا
الانفجارات او حرائق غامضه بالاضافه الى
تعرض اربعين سفينه امدادات حربيه لهجوم
بالقنابل الرصاصيه في عام 1920 عاد
رينتلين لالمانيا ثم انتقل الى لندن وتوفي
هناك في عام
1949 دون ان تخلده منصات التكريم او تذكره
صفحه الشرف